harassment you said rasmus you call it
investment yeah
i guess it depends on what way you're
doing it like if you're
if if i'm like so bait that i'm going
after guys like as in like i'm i can
hunt you can 100
see that like all i'm there for is like
it's just for the money then but if you
ask women what they want one of the
first things they say is ambition why
aren't they shamed for that like the
same way a man if he says big tits he's
going to be shamed
big titties though
as unclear an environment as possible to
inject whatever ideal best suits you so
if you're in a situation where the woman
wants you to say
physical physical physical physical
characteristics then it's cool and if
not that's also cause so the point is to
blur the lines between reality so much
that i can actually tell it's like
hypnotism you know i give you a lot of
words on top and then i actually slowly
inject what i actually want you to to do
that's why
they don't they can't flip with whether
they want ambition or love or kindness
or a tour guide or just anyone or good
sex or protection
it's that's why
what do you guys think
um
[Music]
i think
it's a bit of like accountability for
women i guess
because like
if guys are open and it's okay for them
to be like i want a size six
like i want a girl that's size six or
something then girls have to do it
so
like they're like okay don't say
anything that's so true because if men
say what they want then we have to do it
and then women don't want to like they
don't i feel like modern women are lazy
they're so lazy
and women just love money i don't i
don't get it
i don't know ugly
rich guys guys
once but i think with
money will make him look pretty dude do
you just do you feel like you live in
reality i just found out you're
listening i just feel like i don't know
i've just i just grew up differently all
right listen
go to a therapist and like figure out
what your issue is with that word right
yeah just figure it out figure out
because it's not what is so you're
saying like the way i feel is reality
but let me let me change that word
because i'm using it in in place for
think right
i need to go back to what we were
talking about um
i think i think it's because
i've just been raised i've been raised
by like predominantly men right so i
even though i hear what everyone is
saying i don't think it's always true so
i've also been raised around women that
haven't
are like quite traditional so they're
not really going for their men
because they because of their status or
because of money they're going for them
because they love them they get on
question
so you were raised by men
and traditional women yeah
but you have tattoos and you think
animal attention is harassment what kind
of men were they do you know what i feel
like if i said to my dad oh dad you know
what these guys are chatting to me in
the street he would be offended by that
sounds like a beta do you think any dad
wants to do it to be
no i think i think it might have my dad
would say who cares
that's that's what my dad would say
yeah like
any i just think that's like simp
behavior to like to yeah
to say this that you have a right to be
offended because someone complimented
you that's simp
you think that's the same that's very
simple you would want your child to be i
would i would i would tell my kid to get
over it like why do you want to be a
victim like modern women want to be
victims
like who gives a [ __ ] okay he
complimented you keep walking that's
what i'd say
i want my i want my children to suffer
as much as possible because i want
character
to suffer bro
i had to suffer
hustle bro like
you want them to feel it as well get
bullied for five years and then figure
out i'll drop in and give you some tips
like a good you know
teacher and whatever you know in the
video games where the bot comes in yeah
let's bring back why would you
bring let's bring
back bullet i'm so tired of these hoes
never have been humbled ever in their
life thank you
no
no because honestly if you why would you
want them if you because if you've never
been told you ain't [ __ ] you're gonna
think you're the [ __ ] all the time like
sometimes you need someone to tell you
you ain't [ __ ] you know how lucky i was
to be grow to grow up fat
that humbles you that humble i'm so glad
i had brothers to tell me i was ugly
sometimes yes
that's what brothers do yeah it builds
character but
guess what i've got two of them yeah and
i'm saying but you're i'm saying let's
bring it back let's bring back bullying
why thank you austin i appreciate you
why why
why bring that
sorry i don't know
it's an important part of human
development brain development is to
understand
your place understand that you aren't
you won't have like the mainstream view
all the time you can't have consensus
that chaos is really important for kids
growing up look i don't want to have the
mainstream view but i also don't think
bring back bullying that's ridiculous
come on like bring it back i got bullied
i'm dope it's cool yeah i mean you can
be here people people it's like some of
you some of you have never not been
invited to a party and it shows
some of you have never showed up on
monday and said wait there was something
going on this weekend what do you guys
do it shows it shows
like like why do you think men tease
each other like
women say oh it's toxic masculinity
we're trying to have this consensus
around not thinking and doing things
that are toxic no it's because being
teased teaches you to distance yourself
from words and what you actually are
they actually get hardened to it if i
tell my son your donkey you're silly
you're looking weak right now in in the
right way right i encourage him what is
the right word but how is that the right
way because you don't know how that's
going to affect him that later on down
the line
personal trainer says says you're
looking weak right now you can do one
more you know ex that kind of motivation
but insulting at the same time if the
average at best girl had been told she
was average before it wouldn't have been
such a shock
if she actually had to deal with reality
it wouldn't have been she wouldn't have
had to call into some random guy's
youtube show to be told she can't get a
six-figure guy but that's what happens
when you let women live in delusion for
too long as they start thinking they're
they're they're qualified for something
they're not
and you see it all the time in like just
day-to-day
it breeds self-awareness and you need
that you need self-awareness you can be
self-aware though without without being
bullied but you don't even let me call a
girl a whale even though they are why do
i need to cook blood i feel like i'm
sorry
i could say what i want this is my show
but i'm saying like i don't have to
agree with it but you do that's the
crazy thing is you you know damn well
they're whales you know damn well
they're fat you know damn well that
they're less attractive because they're
fat i'm not saying i'm not saying you
got to be a whale forever i've been fat
you can lose it
like i don't know what what but see like
why is this offensive this shouldn't be
offensive it just is
who had been like why are these women
just complimented me she said like how
are you [ __ ] i'm cute what's going on
here
imagine if men reacted the way women did
i i do that sometimes just to take the
piss
like like i had i had this
time when i was trying out this new
theory so i was like how about i just
make women feel uncomfortable all the
time
when they approach me for no reason just
just to see whether it has an impact and
turns out they love it because when you
make them feel uncomfortable they think
you're the superior social mind they
think your higher status making people
feel small is a very effective way
because actually they need to feel sad
because they're arrogant anyway so it's
like resorting to things like that
because of how the date marker currently
is and do you know what that is that's
fair enough right because i guess like
out of trauma or whatever you're doing
what you're like you're not liking a
circumstance and you're trying
to trauma i mean
it's not